We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David p.
Uh, here's an interesting little voice mail
that I got.
Take a listen to this.
I appreciate the phone call.
I'm gonna run because David backbend, you're
a complete idiot.
They live in a fantasy world.
I live in southern California and you need
distinguish between illegal immigrants and
immigrants, and there's a lot of crime in
my neighborhood from illegal immigrants.
Oh yeah.
So you're so far left.
You're a complete idiot living in a fantasy
world and Tom's going to win again.
And then what's gonna Happen to you?
All your theories are up, down the toilet,
right?
Listen, if Trump gets reelected, it'll be
very good for the show.
It'll be bad for the country, but it will
be good for the show.
I've spoken about this before.
I still don't want him to win, but we'll be
okay.
If Trump wins the show, we'll be better off
than if you lose us, to be quite honest.
Um, as far as there's lots of illegal immigrants
and I don't distinguish, I do distinguish
between legal and illegal immigrants, but
what I've made abundantly clear is that illegal
immigrants commit crimes at a lower rate than
legal immigrants and at a lower rate than
us both born native born individuals.
And it makes sense if you know you're in the
country illegally, you know that if you come
to the attention of police, you risk deportation,
you are incentivized to stay off the radar
of police.
Okay.
We've talked about that a period that that's
really, I can't even think of what else to
say.
Okay.
Today's show almost didn't happen.
We were 10 minutes from having to cancel today's
show.
I will tell you what happened on the bonus
We had what we call our biannual tech disaster
day sort of, but it was actually a much bigger
picture than that involving utility companies
and much more, uh, get access to the bonus
show instantly either by becoming a member@joinpackmandotcomorapatronatpatrion.com
slash [inaudible]
David Pakman show.
I look forward, truly been telling you the
story of what happened today on today's bonus
show in mere man, the David Pakman show@davidpacman.com